um
[Music]
well you know there's some failures
there there somebody failed I go around
Memphis scared every single night
um and I shouldn't be scared I want to
make it to 35. I want to make it past
30. I wish Tyree could have made it past
30.
[Music]
uh 10 o'clock
experience has been very the sun was a
beautiful song he was a good boy
no one's perfect
but he was damn near for a mother to
know that their child was calling them
in their knee and I wasn't feared for
him do you do you know how I feel right
now because I wasn't there for my son
[Music]
that this is the blueprint going forward
no longer can you tell us we gotta wait
six months to a year even though we got
a video with evidence
[Music]
mom
tired I'm tired aren't you tired this is
pain and if you are affected by this do
something
[Music]
no please